متابعه مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
قبل قليل من موسكو للقاء الذي جمع
الرئيسين الصيني والروسي طبعا الرئيس
الصيني هو بزياره رسميه الى موسكو تستمر
ليومين كان
المتحدث باسم الكريم
سيتطرقان الى عده ملفات من اهمها المبادره
الصينيه للسلام بشان اوكرانيا نذكر بانه
الصين حاولت ان تكون جهه سلام وتلعب دور
الوسيط في هذا النزاع حيث نشرت بشهر
فبراير شباط وثيقه من اثنتين عشره نقطه
تدعو فيها الطرفين موسكو وكياف الى وقف
الاعمال العدائيه حسب وصفها والى اجراء
مباحثات
سلام حينها لم تلقى هذه المبادره الصينيه
ترحيبا غربيا طبعا مسائل تطوير العلاقات
الثنائيه بين الطرفين والوضع العالمي
الراهن هو من ابرز المواضيع التي ستضع على
ملف الطاوله نستمع
طبعا نستمع قليلا الى
هذا
الاجتماع من جهتها طبعا الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه استغلت هذه الزياره ودعت
الرئيس الصيني لاستغلال نفوذه مع الجانب
الروسي والضغط على فلاديمير بوتين لواقف
هذه العمليه العسكريه كما تسميها موسكو
والانسحاب من الاراضي المحتله كما وصفتها
نستمع الصين في الاعوام القادمه ستقوم
بخطوه قادمه في تنميتها وستحقق تلك
الاهداف من دون الشركه التي تضعونها نصبه
اعينكم
بشده اننا قد التقينا وقد قمتم بزياره
اولى لكم الينا كرئيس الصين الشعبيه
خلال الوقت القليل المنصرم
قمنا بخطوات كبيره في تنميه علاقتنا
اكثر من مرتين تبادلا تجاري
[موسيقى]
185 مليار دولار
من المهام المشتركه والاهداف
[موسيقى]
انكم شخصيا والاصدقاء الصينيون ايضا
بشكل كبير بتنميه العلاقه الروسيه الصينيه
موقعا عاجلا فيما يتعلق بالمسائل الدوليه
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاوكرانيه